[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 9 mars voici le programme de ce
soir à l'occasion de la Journée
internationale des droits des femmes qui
a eu lieu hier mercredi 8 mars quatre
femmes yvelinoises ont été récompensées
pour leur implication sur le territoire
des prix remis par l'Académie des
pluriels au Grand Trianon du château de
Versailles pour mettre en lumière des
femmes engagées que la société a rendu
invisible nous ferons le point sur cette
soirée avec nos journalistes Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude et Mickaël el midoro
elles arrivent habituellement en avril
au début du printemps les chenilles
processionnaires sont déjà de retour
dans le département pourquoi sont-elles
dangereuses comment les reconnaître nous
poserons ces questions à Alexis Borge
chargé d'études entomologistes à
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement de Guyancourt et puis
comme d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche
du week-end nous vous donnerons nos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines au
programme spectacle de théâtre cirque
concert ce week-end c'est également le
retour de deux événements sur le
territoire le festival régional du
court-métrage au Clayes-sous-Bois et le
Printemps des Poètes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines nous en
parlerons avec nos invités et un plateau
justement avec moi pour parler du
Printemps des Poètes Catherine Baron et
Gilles cheval
alors Catherine vous êtes chargée de la
programmation en écriture contemporaine
et vous Gilles vous êtes spécialiste en
poésie alors à quoi faut-il s'attendre
cette année pour cette 25e édition du
Printemps des Poètes alors écoutez ça
sera le thème et frontières
on en parlera peut-être un peu plus tard
et on va aborder la poésie sous
différentes formes en rencontre en
atelier en spectacle en performance
voilà et alors le thème frontière
vraiment au-delà des frontières avec
des déplacements géographiques mais
aussi intime une programmation assez
riche et sur différentes communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines puisque c'est
aussi dans le cadre du réseau des
médiathèques et donc on fera le point
avec vous un peu plus tard dans cette
émission avec nous également Alexis
Borges bonsoir alors vous êtes chargés
d'études entomologistes à l'office pour
les insectes et leur environnement alors
comment est-ce que vous expliquer le
retour précoce des chenilles
processionnaires dans le département
alors en fait on a eu une fin de une fin
d'année avec un automne assez doux des
univers avec plusieurs jours également
plutôt doux enfin au dessus des normales
saisonnières donc nos chenilles en fait
elles vont lever leur pose et on
continue à s'alimenter et résultats des
courses on a des observations plus
précoces et on a susceptible de les
observer effectivement et dans
différentes
détails tout à l'heure enfin avec nous
nous sommes avec une journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est lynchable
bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde vous allez nous
présenter les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines mais juste
avant jetons un coup d'oeil à la météo
de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le ciel sera encore bien
nuageux sur l'ensemble des Yvelines
prévoyaient quelques averses durant la
matinée au niveau des températures
comptées 9 degrés vers Mantes-la-Jolie
ou dans et Versailles et 8 degrés à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le ciel
sera toujours bien chargé avec de la
pluie côté température il fera 8 degrés
vers Houdan et compter 7 degrés dans les
secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles
et Rambouillet de fortes rafales de vins
sont également à prévoir selon Météo
France tout au long de la journée et
demain nous fêterons la Saint Vivien le
pont maintenant sur l'information dans
les Yvelines
[Musique]
et c'est avec vous Céline charme on
commence par cette information la
première ministre Elisabeth borne s'est
déplacée à la maison Calypso à plaisir
ce jeudi oui Mathilde au lendemain de la
journée internationale des droits des
femmes la première ministre et Elisabeth
borne s'est rendu à la maison Calypso
structure de prise en charge des femmes
victimes de violences de plaisir
accompagné de François Brune ministre de
la santé et de la prévention et de la
ministre délégué chargée notamment de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
Isabelle lomby Rome a notamment présenté
le plan égalité 2027 écouter on veut
dans chaque département déployer une
maison des femmes comme celle que nous
avons visité ce matin on voit à quel
point ça suppose une coordination entre
des professionnels de santé des
intervenants sociaux et donc c'est ce
modèle que nous voulons déployer dans
chacun des départements peut-être sur la
santé des femmes puisque on est aussi
sur un centre de santé sexuelle ici j'ai
eu l'occasion de le dire c'est
évidemment un enjeu important va
poursuivre le plan qui a été lancé sur
la lutte te contre l'endométriose et
puis par ailleurs j'ai annoncé aussi que
nous allions dès l'an prochain assurer
la le remboursement par la Sécurité
sociale des protections périodiques
réutilisables pour les femmes de moins
de 25 ans donc l'actualité également la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites qui s'est poursuivi ce jeudi 9
mars le secteur de l'énergie et
notamment concerné qu'en est-il du
carburant dans les Yvelines alors le
spectre d'une pénurie de carburant
inquiète les automobilistes la grève a
été reconduite sur tous les sites de
Total énergie ce matin la production
n'est pas bloquée n'est plus aucun
carburant ne sort alors même s'il
faudrait des jours voir des semaines
avant que les réserves des 200 dépôts de
carburant répartis sur le territoire
français ne puisse plus approvisionner
les stations services certaines sont
tout de même déjà en rupture partielle
ou totale vous pouvez suivre la
situation en temps réel sur le site qui
s'affiche dans la barre d'infos on
poursuit ces informations Céline avec un
lieu qui sera officiellement inauguré ce
soir depuis décembre le bar de la salle
de spectacle du prisme à Élancourt a
fait peau neuve 55000 euros auront été
nécessaires à la rénovation de ce lieu
culturel 5 antinois durant les trois
mois deux travaux musique jazz en live
les soirs des spectacles les petites
restauration sur place sont proposées ou
faire au public en janvier 2023 cet
espace moderniser sera inaugurée
effectivement ce soir sous le nom de la
ruche on écoute l'équipe du prisme au
micro de Julien Leroy l'idée c'était de
faire quelque chose qui soit industriel
chic qui soit un peu élégant à la à
l'image du prisme c'est-à-dire quelque
chose de d'un peu haut de gamme et puis
effectivement que que notre public
puisse y retrouver on a tout refaire la
partie menuiserie du bar un petit coin
lounge pour que ça soit un peu un peu
sympathique quand on vit entre amis
c'est un lieu qui le retrouve c'est un
lieu qu'il connaisse mais qui là ils le
connaissent mais qui a été qui a été
ravivé et je vois pour avoir discuté
aussi avec eux je vois leur émotion
quand on en parle le marché de
Rambouillet est de nouveau mis à
l'honneur Céline oui le marché de
Rambouillet et de nouveau en lice pour
devenir le plus beau marché de France
TF1 a lancé cette semaine la sixième
édition de son concours votre plus beau
marché et celui de Rambouillet figure
parmi les 8 candidats franciliens si
vous souhaitez le soutenir rendez-vous
sur le site de TF1 et vous pour voter
enfin pour rappel la phase d'inscription
des vœux de parcoursup se termine ce
soir à 23h59 précises après sa date il
ne sera plus possible de rajouter de
nouveaux vœux sur la plateforme à partir
de demain jusqu'au 6 avril ce sera la
phase de confirmation pour cela il
faudra compléter les dossiers avec
notamment des lettres de motivation les
pièces seront directement envoyées aux
établissements d'enseignement supérieur
merci beaucoup Céline Charles et puis
vous aussi comme d'habitude si vous
voyez une information une image qui vous
a marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas
à nous la partager en utilisant le
hashtag 7 8 news ce mercredi 8 mars
c'était la journée internationale des
droits des femmes pour l'occasion des
personnalités féminines des Yvelines ont
été mises à l'honneur au Grand Trianon
du château de Versailles à travers le
prix des pluriels retour sur la première
édition de cette cérémonie avec nos
journalistes Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
et Mickaël midoro des femmes du
département mises à l'honneur au château
de Versailles pour sa première édition
le Prix des pluriel organisés par le
collectif uvinois de l'Académie des
pluriels à réuni des dizaines de
personnalités féminines des Yvelines une
volonté de mettre en lumière des femmes
qui agissent au niveau local au niveau
de leur ville au niveau de leur immeuble
au niveau de leur quartier donc là il
s'agissait aujourd'hui à Versailles
voilà de les mettre en valeur et de leur
faire aussi prendre conscience que ce
qu'elles font à une grande valeur
l'événement a été construit au
partenariat avec des associations et les
mairies de trois communes des Yvelines
Saint-Germain-en-Laye Mantes-la-Ville et
Les Mureaux une élection sans candidate
et son jury sans jury que personne ne ne
sélectionne réellement à partir d'un
dossier ou pas de il y a pas de concours
en revanche ce sont les femmes entre
elles une fois qu'elles sont dominées
puis finalistes se sont elles qui
définissent et qui choisissent qui sont
les lauréates en fonction de critères
qu'elle même définissent
journée du droit des femmes 12
finalistes ont été honorés pour moi
c'est une grande c'est un grand jour et
c'est un bel événement que nous vivons
surtout qu'on a été honoré dans ce beau
château et c'est juste une fierté voilà
l'objectif est également de créer un
réseau solidaire de femmes sur le
territoire en fait entre elles à force
de se connaître peuvent se soutenir sur
des projets peuvent voilà tout
simplement c'est l'idée c'est de créer
une synergie le Collectif Citoyen veut
désormais renouveler l'expérience pour
une deuxième édition les fondateurs
visent plus loin espèrent développer
dans les prochaines années le prix
pluriel au niveau national
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission les
chenilles processionnaires sont déjà de
retour dans les Yvelines elles sont
censées arriver au début du printemps
vers le mois d'avril mais sont déjà bien
présentes dans certaines communes des
Yvelines pour en parler avec nous Alexis
Borges le rappelle pour ce qui n'était
pas là avec nous au début de cette
émission vous êtes entomologiste à
l'office pour les insectes et leurs
environnements alors c'est chenilles
processionnaires il en existe de
plusieurs espèces et elles sont
nuisibles est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi alors le terme
nuisible elle est à prendre entre
guillemets effectivement parce que ça
dépend comment se positionne en fait
finalement en fait elles sont faut
savoir qu'elles sont présentes en fait
en Europe de façon très large depuis 100
ans après Jésus-Christ donc ce qu'on a
pas des espèces invasives on a vraiment
des espèces autochtones de notre faune
française certaines années il y a un peu
plus de
chenilles donc d'observation
automatiquement les dérèglements qui
sont liés des fois notre mode de vie on
manipule un peu le végétal on va
importer des des pins ce qui s'agit pour
celles qu'on observe en ce moment de
processionnaires du pain donc là ce
qu'on appelle l'en résinement va faire
qu'on va pouvoir attirer quelque part
l'établissement de ces chenilles hors de
ces milieux où elles ont leurs
prédateurs suffisant à une régulation
naturelle donc ces chenilles
effectivement faut en parler puisque ce
sont les deux seuls espèces qui sont
vraiment j'irai dangereuses pour l'homme
et non pas du zip c'est-à-dire qu'au
niveau de la santé humaine il y a
vraiment un risque si on les manipule
alors les risques c'est que en fait ce
sont les seuls avoir une protéine qui va
entraîner via en fait la réception de
leur poils qui peuvent être donc
volatiles c'est à dire qu'ils sont
obligés d'avoir lâchés par la chenille
et après avec le vent les déplacements
d'air des poils vont pouvoir toucher
donc les mammifères dont on fait partie
et éventuellement donc les animaux de
compagnie qui peuvent s'amuser à leur
truffe dedans pour les pour les chiens
les chevaux etc donc suite à ça on va
avoir vraiment une suite de une cascade
potentielle de réaction ça veut aller
des démangeaisons des des
œdèmes éventuellement à des soinsment ça
peut aller jusqu'à des nécrose pour des
imaginer un chien qui va s'amuser à
mâchouiller plusieurs chenilles donc
c'est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est voilà
et rappeler ce sont les deux seuls
chenilles qui vont ses caractéristiques
de dangerosités sont les deux seuls
avoir cette protéine particulière qui
entraîne toutes ces réactions donc
comment les reconnaître alors là on a
une facilité avec cette chenille et puis
ça sa cousine qui est également présente
dans les Yvelines mais qu'on voit un peu
moins alors la première celle du pain
qu'on voit actuellement tout simplement
ce qu'il y a descend des pins pour aller
ce qu'on avait ce nymphoser se
transformer en papillon en chenille ça
donne un papillon donc à ce moment elles
ont besoin de se transformer dans la
terre donc à descente de leur art et
après donc elles vont s'enfuir et on on
voit bien parce que ce sont des
chenilles grégaires c'est-à-dire
qu'elles vivent à plusieurs ensemble
autour de leur plante haute leur plante
de nourrissage et quand elles descendent
et continuent à faire ça ensemble c'est
juste dans le sol qui est finalement
juste avant de rentrer dans le sol qui
vont se finalement se séparer mais font
quand même des chrysalides alors leur
stade immobile de transformation elles
le font quand même côte à côte donc
c'est vraiment le moment où il faut
vraiment prêter attention c'est en ce
moment puisque on a de l'avance comment
quand on marche en forêt faut faire
attention
on les voit de loin c'est c'est des
colonnes ça fait vraiment une colonne un
militaire c'est les seuls également à
faire ça ça se distingue facilement on
n'aura pas une autre espèce qui qui
agira ainsi et en plus ce sont les seuls
liés au pain donc quand vous avez des
pins et vous voyez cette procession nous
leur nom voilà vous êtes à coup sûr de
de tomber sur cette espèce alors que
faire si jamais on a été piqué pendant
que ça va vraiment dépendre de la façon
dont on a finalement eu réceptionner ses
poils donc je vous ai dit des fois
l'animal de compagnie ou le petit enfant
peut toucher la chenille donc la
première chose à savoir c'est voilà que
il y a un risque donc quand on est
parent c'est vraiment prévenir ne nous
donne pas toucher même si on a un doute
je n'ai poilu on est vite dit toucher
après ça va être voilà si on a des
démangeaisons ça va être de se laver
abondamment à l'eau tout simplement si
on a les muqueuses qui sont touchées on
va utiliser par exemple des sérums
physiologiques après si ça va plus loin
faut pas hésiter à consulter un ophtalmo
un ophtalmologiste ou un médecin ça peut
entraîner éventuellement des problèmes
respiratoires tout ça ça va dépendre de
la quantité en fait de poils qu'on a
géré à savoir que les poils qui ont cet
effet sont des poils quasi
microscopiques ils font moins de devoir
font 0,2 mm donc des fois on voit des
chenilles avec plein de poils ça c'est
un effet protecteur touffu il plaît pas
des prédateurs eux c'est vraiment les
micro-poiles qui peuvent se détacher et
quand vous avez des coups de vent ça
peut amplifier le phénom qui imaginez
voilà ces chenilles dans une cour
d'école il y a vraiment un risque en
général voilà les communes les
agglomérations sont assez conscientes de
ce problème là donc elles savent prendre
les devants et enlever les nids qui
durent du début de l'automne jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant en fait c'est ma
prochaine question comment est-ce qu'on
fait pour limiter leur prolifération bah
en fait il faut justement agir quand
elles sont regroupées plus facilement
accessibles c'est-à-dire en fait couper
alors on parle de nid en fait une espèce
de grande bourse soyeuse des chenilles
fabriquent de la soie toutes les
chenilles peuvent fabriquer de la soie
elles sont grégaires font une espèce de
grande bourse dans lequel elles vont se
loger donc des fois elles vont se
déplacer et refaire un nid dans un dans
l'arbre plus loin pour manger en fait ou
réguler la température et limiter
l'action des prédateurs une sorte de
protection et de régulation de
température et d'humidité donc à ce
moment-là quand elles sont toutes à
l'intérieur un peu comme un nid par
exemple de guêpes et ben on va s'amuser
enfin c'est pas le mot on va les couper
le bout de branche dans ce sur le quai
des accrocher Sony et après soit
l'incinéré soit voilà le détruire
autrement mais voilà c'est la solution
la plus efficace si on s'y prend un peu
trop tard il y a des ce qu'on appelle
des collerettes qui peuvent être mis
autour des pins donc pas les autres
armes on les aura aucun intérêt
puisqu'elle ne mange uniquement que les
pins les processus du pain les
processions processionnaires du chêne
dont on verra un peu un peu plus tard
mais qui ne descend jamais au sol elles
sont uniquement liées aux chaînes c'est
plutôt en automne les professionnels du
chêne non alors les chenilles non ça va
être ça va être à la suite on va être à
la mi printemps on peut en voir jusqu'à
début juin et après voilà vont se
transformer en papillon mais elle elle
des fois elle marque moins puisqu'elle
descendent pas au sol donc elles vont
vraiment rester dans l'arbre donc la
collerette n'aura pas m'intérêt est-ce
que c'est quand les chenilles du pain
veulent descendre au sol qu'on va les
intercepter via une espèce d'entonnoir
qui ceinture l'arbre avec un gros sac
collecteur avec de la terre en
finalement ils vont faire leur
chrysalide au lieu de la faire dans le
sol elles vont la faire dans le sac
qu'elles prennent pour le sol et donc ça
limite le contact de dépassant des
promener en forêt par exemple donc voilà
c'est vraiment les méthodes les plus
efficaces et surtout pas nuisibles à une
biodiversité qui est là pour réguler
justement ces chenilles à les coucou les
mésanges les huppes les chauves-souris
qui vont manger soit les adultes de
cette chemise soit les chenilles donc il
y a vraiment une bonne régulation et ce
dysfonctionnement fait que des fois
effectivement on peut avoir plus de
chenilles mais l'année d'après on
enverra moins ce que la régulation est
censée fonctionner et bien merci
beaucoup Alexis Borge d'avoir accepté
notre invitation on va continuer de
parler des animaux mais pas des insectes
c'est l'heure de passer à notre
chronique sur le bien-être animal avec
ATIS barré
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir Mathilde alors je
le rappelle vous êtes conseillère
municipal en charge du bien-être animal
pour la ville de Poissy et ce soir vous
allez nous parler des lapins et vous
êtes venus avec une lapine alors un
lapin en fait un lapin cannelle donc je
suis venue accompagnée de cannelle qui
est un peu craintif ce soir alors
entendu parler de chenille à poil je
crois que c'est un peu donc elle a une
particularité c'est qu'elle mord les
vêtements et ce soir voilà j'ai ramené
aussi son petit coussin ou à la un petit
peu mordu et mais par contre il faut
surtout pas la punir un lapin ne doit
pas être punition et pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle mord les vêtements ou les tissus
à leur ATIS alors elle fait ses dents et
puis aussi c'est un signe où elle a
besoin de caresses d'accord et pourquoi
est-ce qu'il ne faut jamais punir en
latin alors le lapin en fait c'est un
animal qui est très intelligent il
apprend très vite il n'a pas besoin
qu'on ose la voix mais également très
craintif donc il faut l'encourager le
motiver en fait il faut être comme un
coach d'équipe pour pouvoir la motiver
et puis le vous rendra très bien alors
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres choses à
savoir sur le caractère du lapin alors
le lapin il est très doux il est très
sociable c'est un animal en fait qui a
été un animal de domestiqué à partir du
15e siècle on l'appelle le NAC
aujourd'hui le nouvel animal de
compagnie c'est un animal donc qui est
agréable à vivre si la confiance en vous
il vit en groupe et pour marquer son
territoire donc lui est une proie il a
marqué son territoire avec de l'urine
avec de la grotte et avec autre glande
à l'âge de la maturité sexuelle il va
être agressif donc il est conseillé de
le stériliser entre 6 et 12 mois
d'accord et ce qu'il y a des choses
aussi à prendre en compte si on souhaite
adopter un lapin au niveau de son
habitat par exemple oui alors au niveau
de son habitat donc je conseille une
très grande cage pour qu'il ait une cage
en hauteur pour qu'il ait la place pour
ses pattes arrières qui soit dans le
calme et il est diurne donc le soir
ouvrir sa cage pour qu'il puisse faire
son petit tour et puis bien protégé vos
meubles et les câbles de vos téléphones
fixes si vous en avez encore et pareil
est-ce qu'il faut savoir des choses sur
son entretien oui concernant son
entretien donc vérifie bien ses oreilles
ses yeux et surtout sa dentition donc
s'il avait des problèmes au niveau de
l'occlusion il aurait des difficultés à
s'alimenter bien le brosser bien sûr
pour éviter les parasites et puis en
période de mue aussi et surtout bah on
voit un lapin c'est c'est mignon c'est
tellement mignon qu'on croit à chaque
fois que c'est une femelle
c'est pas une peluche parce que cannelle
a une histoire particulière en fait elle
a été ça a été un achat compulsif d'une
famille avec plusieurs enfants en bas
âge la lettre abandonnée la forêt donc
là j'ai demandé à la personne de nous
l'apporter en mairie de Poissy cannelle
est arrivée à l'accueil et notre agent
de la vie de Poissy qui s'appelle
Virginie que je salue la immédiatement
adopté et bien sûr elle s'appuie sur ses
filles
Océane et Morgane qui s'en occupent avec
très grande responsabilité donc je tiens
à aller féliciter et aller saluer merci
encore
Océane et Morgane et alors que
mangent-ils ce lapin à part les
vêtements du coup alors il est herbivore
c'est un très bon exemple pour les
enfants et pour les maris ils mangent
des légumes ils mangent des Brooks
bien-être oui vous me trouvez
prochainement avec un autre invité je
dis peut-être une tortue ça va dépendre
de son planning d'accord et ben on a
hâte de voir ça en tout cas on passe un
tout autre sujet à présent visiter le
hangar de l'association univers ne sera
bientôt plus possible l'association qui
restaure les véhicules de guerre à
Versailles et menacées d'expulsion elle
doit quitter les lieux pour laisser
place aux travaux des nouvelles lignes
du métro du Grand Paris le reportage de
Régine ralech je suis donc chargeur
charme la munition dans le cadre
principal
la culasse se referme mise à feu du
tireur la douille est éjectée le
chargeur récupère la munition encore
chaude et éjecte la munition en dehors
du char par les coutilles qui est située
derrière moi ce que vous veniez de voir
c'est le chargement du canon d'un
chercheur man datant de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale si cette démonstration
est possible c'est grâce à l'association
Versailles univers depuis 50 ans elle
restaure des véhicules de guerre pour
les ramener à la vie et les faire
défiler lors de commémoration pour nous
c'est vraiment important la conservation
du patrimoine et la continuité du devoir
de mémoire puisque ça nous permet de
sauver de la casse des véhicules c'est à
la fois notre passion et puis ça nous
rend très très fier quand on a des
vétérans qui ont connu le conflit qui
savent que c'est la guerre surtout dans
le contexte actuel et qui nous laisse
une marque indélébile sur notre véhicule
et qui reconnaissent que notre travail
sert à quelque chose mais une contrainte
vient de s'ajouter à leur planning le
projet du Grand Paris pour construire
l'une de ces nouvelles lignes de métro
le camp militaire perd une partie de ses
terrains et doit se réorganiser notre
contrainte que nous avons actuellement
donc c'est effectivement c'est trop des
nouveaux locaux dans volume capacité au
minima de 3000 m² afin de préserver la
collection dans un premier temps et dans
un deuxième temps c'est effectivement
avoir donc une partie musée où on puisse
mieux accueillir le public l'association
qui compte 170 bénévoles à solliciter
plusieurs communes des Yvelines pour
trouver des locaux ils ont jusqu'au mois
d'août 2023 pour quitter les lieux
[Musique]
on va parler de cinéma à présent
dimanche prochain se déroule la 11e
édition du festival régional du
court-métrage aux Clayes-sous-Bois pour
en parler avec nous à distance Nawel Ben
Ahmed bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes médiatrice
culturelle à l'espace Philippe Noiret
aux Clayes-sous-Bois au total vous avez
sélectionné 11 courts métrages sur des
thèmes assez variés comment est-ce que
vous les choisissez ces festivals
alors c'est court métrage cette année en
fait ils ont été choisis par un groupe
de spectateurs de l'espace noir et en
fait les abonnés à notre newsletter on a
fait un appel comme ça et donc sur le
volontariat plusieurs personnes ont vu
tous les films et on sélectionné selon
leur gouttes voilà de spectateurs
respectives et comme ça ils sont arrivés
à trouver 11 films on se court-métrage
qui leur vraiment qui les a tous réunis
et donc ils sont tous vraiment très
impatients de les montrer à tout le
monde et il y a une durée limitée par
exemple il faut pas qu'ils excède de 15
minutes 20 minutes
alors en fait le but c'était d'avoir en
tout trois heures de films et de se
retrouver donc avec deux sessions d'une
heure 30 donc on a essayé de de pas
choisir les films forcément selon leur
durée donner leur chance à tous les
films mais c'est vrai que parfois par
contre des films ont dû être un petit
peu
choisis ou éliminer s'ils étaient trop
long trop court pour rentrer dans ces
trottes dans ces trois heures pardon et
donc on se retrouve avec 11 films alors
que les années précédentes c'était
plutôt 15 films au 16 film et donc au
niveau des thèmes c'est assez varié on
le disait à l'instant il y a vraiment
des courts métrages qui abordent des
thèmes sérieux et d'autres un petit peu
plus comique
oui oui il y a vraiment pour tous les
goûts cette année il y a de la comédie
de l'action de la science-fiction du
documentaire enfin c'est vraiment
comment dire une série de courts
métrages très différents mais tous de
d'une très grande qualité et au niveau
des réalisateurs est-ce que ce sont
souvent les mêmes qui reviennent ou vous
avez où vous avez aussi des débutants
non cette année la plupart sont des
débutants c'est la première fois qu'on
les accueille au festival il y a juste
un réalisateur qui a déjà fait une
petite festival pardon une année
précédente mais sinon c'est tous des
nouveaux réalisateurs et en plus on a la
chance cette année sur 11 films 10 films
seront représentés donc des réalisateurs
seront là pour parler de leur film et à
répondre aux questions donc c'est
vraiment une grande chance qu'on a cette
année et alors quel est l'objectif de ce
festival c'est mettre en avant des
courts-métrages qui ne seront pas
forcément diffusés dans les salles de
cinéma
oui voilà tout à fait en fait l'objectif
c'est pour le spectateurs de montrer la
forme du court-métrage qui finalement
n'est pas forcément toujours valorisé au
cinéma donc l'idée c'est vraiment de
pouvoir faire découvrir un autre
spectateur une nouvelle forme de film et
aussi des nouveaux réalisateurs les
faire émerger et participer aussi à
développer leur carrière et ce qu'il y a
un court-métrage qui vous a marqué plus
qu'un autre vous
oui moi il y a un court-métrage qui est
libre interdit c'est un documentaire en
fait sur une librairie en Slovénie qui
accueille tous les livres interdits à
travers le monde tous les livres qui
sont censurés ils sont ressemblés pardon
dans cette librairie et c'est un
documentaire vraiment très très
intéressant et qui nous apprend beaucoup
de choses et alors cette année le
festival est sous la présidence de
l'acteur émetteur en scène Alexis
Michalik c'est un honneur pour vous une
fierté
voilà tout à fait en fait à la fin de
chaque session on garde un petit temps
d'échange avec les réalisateurs ensuite
une pause qui permet quand même au
public de respirer parce qu'on se rend
compte que trois heures de visionnage ça
peut être intense donc après cette pause
on repart sur une deuxième session et
encore une fois après
l'interview de réalisateur sachant que
les réalisateurs seront là aussi pour
répondre informellement lors de de la
pause au bar etc pour échanger avec les
spectateurs et donc à la toute fin au
final de ces trois heures de visionnage
on vote pour le court-métrage favori du
jury de qui il est composé le jury cette
année
alors le jury qu'on vous dit de
plusieurs personnes de professionnels de
la culture donc à Lexi Michalik
évidemment qui est le président du jury
il est aussi composé Daida asgada
zaredev pardon qui en fait est une
méthode ancienne et qui est comment dire
à l'origine de la pièce pour que
personne qu'on diffuse la veille et qui
travaille qui est dans le cercle aussi
d'Alexis Michalik ainsi que Régis vallée
qui est un comédien et puis aussi on
nous avons un placard qui est de la
culture des Clayes-sous-Bois qui
participent au jury donc ça permet
vraiment d'avoir différents points de
vue pour pour choisir les trois films
préférés du juriste qui sera pas évident
j'en suis sûr et donc au total il y a
six trophées à gagner
deux trophées du meilleur comédien
meilleur comédienne les trois prix du
jury et le prix du public puisque les
spectateurs peuvent voter pour leur
court-métrage favoris alors justement
comment ça va se passer concrètement
comment est-ce que les spectateurs vont
pouvoir voter
alors quand les spectateurs arrivent en
fait on leur donne le programme des
courts métrages à l'intérieur il y a un
petit bulletin de vote qu'ils vont
garder précieusement et à la fin de la
deuxième session il y aura une urne dans
laquelle ils pourront déposer leurs
bulletin pour pour donner leur vote et
ce qui a des critères qui font un peu
plus pencher la balance le jeu des
acteurs le scénario la musique
oui je après je pense que ça dépend de
chaque personne chaque personne va
vraiment voter selon son affinité pour
certains films il y a peut-être des
thématiques qui vont plaire comme je
vous ai dit le documentaire peut-être
que ça va plaire après il y a d'autres
personnes qui vont peut-être en effet
être par rapport aux jeux d'acteurs à
chaque fois c'est une surprise donc on
sait pas chacun avec son avec son propre
avis et bien merci beaucoup Nawel
benamen d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je le rappelle le festival régional du
court-métrage aux Clayes-sous-Bois se
déroulera le 12 mars à l'Espace Philippe
Noiret des Clayes-sous-Bois de 14h à 19h
l'entrée est ouverte à tous et à l'aide
gratuite
[Musique]
et nous avons été rejoints en plateau
par deux journalistes de la rédaction de
TV 78 Grégory canalet bonsoir Mathilde
c'est vous qui allez animer le quiz il
est sur quoi ce soir journée
internationale des droits des femmes
nous allons jouer sur la thématique des
femmes célèbres dans les Yvelines elles
sont nombreuses à avoir marqué de leur
empreinte de leur empreinte l'histoire
du territoire l'histoire de France et ce
à toutes les époques de répondre à vos
questions comme d'habitude vous Gabriel
vous nous présentez vos idées de sortie
pour le week-end alors pareil petite
teasing de quoi est-ce que vous allez
nous parler ce soir oui Mathilde on
parlera notamment d'une pièce de théâtre
une pièce de théâtre qui se joue au
Théâtre de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors c'est vendredi et samedi soir et
elle retrace vous le verrez l'histoire
de la télévision française on apprend
pas mal de choses je vous en parlerai
dans quelques instants on en parlait
dans quelques instants mais avant on va
parler de la 25e édition du Printemps
des Poètes organisé par le réseau des
médiathèques et les écritures
contemporaines de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines l'événement
pour cette année avec au programme des
spectacles des ateliers des rencontres
des podcasts et des lectures un
programme très riche pour en parler avec
nous Catherine baron vous êtes chargés
de la programmation pour les écritures
contemporaines et Gilles cheval vous
êtes spécialiste en poésie alors le
thème de cette année vous nous l'avez
dit au tout début de cette émission
c'est frontière alors pourquoi ce thème
baron qu'est-ce qui vous évoque alors
déjà c'est en fait le Printemps des
Poètes est une opération nationale donc
c'est eux qui ont choisi chaque année
c'est une lettre de l'alphabet voilà
donc là c'était F frontière après c'est
vrai que c'est d'actualité puisqu'on
passe de plus en plus
les frontières à tous les niveaux
pour le Printemps des Poètes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il s'agit
surtout de passer au-delà des frontières
dans vers l'ouverture la découverte de
l'autre d'autres poésies puisqu'on a une
franco-tunisienne
Gilles pourra mieux en parler pour le 11
mars
à la médiathèque du canal et qui est
donc effectivement Franco tunisienne et
c'est la maison on parle de frontières
géographique mais il n'y a pas que ça
c'est à dire que je suis assez quand
même étonné c'est un peu une constante
finalement auprès des poètes ils n'ont
pas tellement de frontières pas
tellement de limite c'était vert qu'il
voilà ben krayem et poète les musiciens
allaient chanteuses à des comédiennes et
beaucoup des intervenants de cette année
du Printemps des poètes sont comme elle
il y a un metteur en scène également qui
interviendra qui est poète également
enfin voilà c'est quelque chose qui est
assez impressionnant et
voilà ça se vérifie chaque année mais je
trouve que cette année marche c'est pas
ce qui a fait exprès mais quand même là
c'est bien trouvé
alors on va tout de suite préciser par
rapport au programme
Nawel en fait est bloqué par les
transports et la elle enchaîne les
concerts en ce moment à Toulouse et du
coup samedi la rencontre qui était
prévue à la médiathèque non à la
librairie du pavé du canal
sera en fait non pas 15 heures mais à
l'issue de son concert dont il va parler
la lecture concert a lieu à 17h à la
médiathèque du canal et la rencontre qui
devait avoir lieu à l'origine à la
librairie bas se fera à la médiathèque
dans la foulée de la lecture concerne il
est libraire sera présent le pavé du
canal parce que c'est important de
parler des libraires de proximité il
sera présent également sur d'autres
d'autres moments du Printemps des poètes
qui se déroulent jusqu'au 25 mars inclus
et d'ailleurs le 25 mars Gilles vous
allez animer deux rencontres oui je vais
animer une rencontre avec Cécile oumani
qui est également Franco tunisienne
parce que décidément les frontières
et britanniques voilà oui une rencontre
avec Cécile Roumanie qui a déjà publié
des dizaines de livres ça fait 25 ans
qu'elle publie et là on parlera de son
nouveau livre avec
c'est la petite cerise sur le gâteau un
peu de musique avec Louis Catala
violoncelliste et ça se passe donc à la
médiathèque des Clayes-sous-Bois le 25 à
17h30 18h30 je ne sais plus en même
temps
de rencontres et une programmation
tellement riche que on se perd il y a
aussi des spectacles de chant qui sont
au programme alors comment est-ce qu'on
lit en fait au final la poésie avec le
chant
alors déjà les poètes ont toujours
travaillé avec tous les artistes le
mélange souvent en transversalité
là par exemple pour Frida Kahlo et les
poètes il y aura donc trois musiciens de
jazz qui vont à la fois interpréter des
musiques en lien avec le Mexique avec
Frida Kahlo et puis il y aura des
lectures de texte de Paul Éluard
d'Aragon
également de Frida Kahlo puisqu'elle a
écrit des poèmes notamment dans ces
lettres d'amour à Diego
voilà donc ça se marie très très bien
également
pour Nawel elle tira certains de ses
poèmes tout en chantant également
qui est aussi
compositeur qui travaillent énormément
avec des musiciens là il n'y aura pas de
musiciens mais la partition qu'il va
jouer avec Frédéric Bruyas ça sera très
musical
et je tiens à souligner d'ailleurs que
c'est une création exprès pour notre
Printemps des Poètes à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines de même que le
Frida Kahlo le 18 mars à plaisir au
théâtre Robert Manuel
en partenariat avec la ville
ça vous évoque quoi vous la poésie
Grégory canalet Gabriel bonsier sur la
thématiquement frontière ça me donne
plus l'impression que c'est frontières
sont pas infranchissables grâce aux mots
on va pouvoir aller au-delà de ces
frontières et frontières géographiques
des frontières de l'esprit on va pouvoir
aller au-delà avec la poésie voilà la
question que j'avais envie de vous poser
c'est pourquoi c'est un événement
justement qui revient chaque année mais
pourquoi c'est un événement important
pourquoi il faut défendre la poésie lors
de cet événement selon vous
alors parce que la poésie n'est pas très
du moins la poésie actuelle
contemporaine n'est pas très présente en
librairie ou un radio ou à la télévision
donc alors que les poètes créent
énormément et s'agit encore une fois
pour beaucoup mieux en parler avec moi
les maisons d'édition font un travail
absolument remarquable je te laisse
poursuivre et en vérité les poètes sont
partout mais on les voit très peu c'est
une scène entre guillemets une scène
très peu médiatisée c'est un petit peu
comme la chanson française à l'heure
actuelle il y a des festivals qui lui
sont consacrés il y a un public très
fidèle mais ce n'est pas médiatisé on
n'entend pas parler de beaucoup de
chanteurs français à l'heure actuelle et
pour les poètes c'est un peu la même
chose alors qu'en fait ils sont
absolument essentiels et ils
interviennent partout c'est à dire qu'on
a toujours cette image un petit peu
caricaturale du poète et de la poésie
complètement déconnecté de la réalité
enfermé dans son monde alors que c'est
tout l'inverse les poètes ne sont pas
juste là pour écrire des poèmes ils sont
là pour transmettre lors d'ateliers ils
vont partout dans des écoles ils font
énormément de rencontres ils montent sur
scène donc là il touche encore à autre
chose on en parlait tout à l'heure il
touche à la musique à la performance
enfin c'est oui c'est important de les
mettre en avant vraiment parce que c'est
une scène absolument passionnante il y
en a vraiment pour tous les goûts et
contrairement à ce qu'on imagine c'est
extrêmement accessible voilà il suffit
de se laisser porter c'est la musique
des mots donc si on aime la musique on
est obligé d'aimer la poésie peut-être
toute la poésie mais au moins certaines
choses
justement vous pensez qu'il y a un enjeu
à mettre en avant la poésie notamment
pour les nouvelles générations les plus
jeunes pour qui ça peut-être tendance à
se perdre un petit peu cette pratique de
des œuvres politiques alors je dirais on
n'est pas obligé de lire de la poésie
quand on est enfant même si dans
l'absolu c'est quand même dommage de
s'en priver mais
de toute façon on en retrouve dans les
livres pour enfants il y a pas besoin de
chercher très très loin à toutes les
pages j'ai envie de vous dire voilà
c'est très accessible et la pratique de
la poésie fait énormément de bien aux
enfants j'ai eu l'occasion de le de le
constater à plusieurs reprises c'est
assez impressionnant de voir à quel
point ça peut débloquer des enfants sur
l'écriture voilà d'un point de vue
purement pragmatique clairement c'est
une forme qui laisse énormément de
liberté qui laisse beaucoup de place à
l'imaginaire et pour des enfants c'est
c'est magnifique et généralement les
derniers de la classe sont les meilleurs
jeux et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
cette année pour le Printemps des Poètes
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on fait un
focus
sur une revue de poésie junior qui a été
créée par le Centre de Création jeunesse
de Tinqueux qui a un centre magnifique
près de Reims
matteiya bisniaque qui le dirige et la
crée d'ailleurs un festival de poésie
jeunesse qui est le seul en France et
donc Gustave junior cette revue c'est un
quatre pages en numérique qui met en
valeur des poètes actuels qui écrivent
pas seulement pour les enfants
et donc les médiathèques vont faire un
focus sur cette revue en
mettant en exposant des poèmes de
dominique Sampiero de carnora de Pierre
Soletti donc voilà là les enfants
pour en trouver
matière à découvrir et
on a une création justement autour de
cette revue par une poète Laura luthar
qui est également comédienne le 15 mars
à la médiathèque Anatole France
appartient de cette revue peuvent faire
une lecture
Gustave
alors c'est une surprise c'est en
création donc je peux pas en dire plus
venez
j'ai le cheval d'avoir répondu à nos
questions alors pour rappel le Printemps
des Poètes c'est du 10 au 25 mars à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous
retrouverez toute la programmation sur
le site internet des médiathèques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et c'est
gratuit l'entrée est libre d'accès allez
c'est l'heure maintenant de passer à nos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines avec
vous Gabriel Gonthier on commence par
quoi ce soir et bien Mathieu on commence
avec une pièce qui se joue au théâtre de
Saint-Quentin sublime alors c'est
vendredi et samedi soir je voulais dit
elle s'intitule une télévision française
Thomas Quillardet metteur en scène nous
en parle un spectacle que j'ai que j'ai
écrit et qui raconte l'histoire de enfin
l'histoire un bout de l'histoire de TF1
c'est un spectacle qui est comme une
fresque fresque industrielle une saga un
petit peu sur comment TF1 a évolué à
créer un nouveau mode de journaliste
entre les années
4-1985 et 1995 alors la télévision est
un thème peu abordé par le théâtre cette
pièce elle revient sur un épisode
marquant de son histoire la
privatisation de TF1 par le gouvernement
Chirac c'était en 1987 c'est au groupe
de BTP présidé par Francis Bouygues que
sera attribuée la chaîne la pièce Mèze
mêle ainsi à la fois la fiction et le
documentaire et le samedi 11 mars à
19h30 c'est un débat autour du thème de
l'information maltraité qui est
organisée Gabriel oui le met en scène
réunira François robinet maître de
conférence en histoire et spécialiste
des médias mais aussi Patrice Carnoux
ancien rédacteur en chef de et
journaliste pardon sur TF1 et sur France
Télévisions et actuelle directeur de
l'information ici à Télé 78 le débat
sera modéré par Nathalie Wolf maître de
conférence à l'UVSQ alors du théâtre
mais également du cirque Gabriel ce
week-end avec les dernières
représentations du cirque Zavatta à
l'île de loisirs de Trappes oui depuis
le 18 février 2023 le cirque Zavatta
doucher fait étape à l'île de loisirs de
Trappes ce weekend ce sont les dernières
dates si vous souhaitez assister à leur
nouveau spectacle de 2 heures au
programme du spectacle oley danseur de
flamenco cavalerie cracheur de feu ou
encore numéro aérien des animaux
exotiques seront également présents si
vous êtes intéressé rendez-vous donc
sous le chapiteau samedi c'est à 16h et
dimanche à 15h Mathilde vous allez nous
parler de stand-up à présent Gabriel
avec un grand nom de l'humour sur la
scène de la Meurisse attrape encore oui
l'humoriste et comédienne Caroline
Vigneaux après quitter la robe elle
remonte sur scène pour présenter son
spectacle croque la pomme dans lequel
comme elle elle goûte aux fruits défendu
de l'arbre de la connaissance depuis de
dimanche dans un spectacle vivant qui
sera présenté entre danse humour théâtre
et même musique et ce spectacle
s'inscrit dans un projet plus global oui
ce spectacle il est proposé dans le
cadre du festival show meuf Gohan
soutenu par la Ville dans le cadre de
son travail sur l'égalité homme-femme et
dont l'humoriste et la marraine des
spectacles vont donc être joué toute la
semaine à l'auditorium du conservatoire
et à la Meurice et on termine en musique
Gabriel en musique et toujours attrape
samedi à 18h les solistes de la
ville-dieu vous donne rendez-vous à
l'auditorium du Conservatoire de Musique
et de Danse parmi eux Marianne picotti
Guillaume dure en Picoti et Xavier
Philips il présente le trio des esprits
de Beethoven ou encore le trio numéro 2
de Schubert les solistes de la
ville-dieu se produisent depuis
plusieurs années en partenariat avec
pour la promotion de la musique à 50 ans
apmsq cette année l'association elle
fête ses 20 ans pour votre dernier idée
de sortie on change un peu de registre
on change de registre mais on reste en
musique cette fois on va parler électro
la ville de plaisir propose un concert
samedi à 20h30 à la clé des champs au
programme de cette soirée je vous le
donne en mille principalement de
l'électro et de la techno parmi les
artistes présents Elsa do Brasil Arnaud
Rebotini ce qui est notamment le
compositeur du film 120 battements par
minute ou encore le duo double Merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier pour vos idées
de sortie alors comme d'habitude petit
tour de plateau est-ce que il y a une
idée qui qui vous a un peu plus
intéressé qu'une autre Caroline Caroline
et vous Catherine alors le Théâtre de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines la soirée
de l'histoire de la télévision
l'histoire des médias qui nous
concernent aussi directement donc moi
aussi j'opterai pour cette pièce de
théâtre et bien vous êtes raccord on
continue avec le quiz Grégory alors vous
me l'avez dit vous allez me challenger
sur les femmes célèbres qui ont été deux
passages ou qui ont été dans les
Yvelines je vous laisse tout un lien
avec les Yvelines elles sont célèbres au
niveau de l'histoire de France même vous
êtes prêt pour le quiz nous inviter vous
jouez avec nous
on est prêt il y a pas eu de oui mais on
va dire que vous êtes tous prêts alors
on va parler de Louise Weiss pour
commencer une femme de lettres
journaliste et grande Défenseur des
droits des femmes et aussi des valeurs
européennes tout au long de sa vie elle
est née dans une famille alsacienne mais
elle a un lien avec les Yvelines et
notamment avec la ville de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine Louise Weiss
c'est à l'origine de la création d'un
musée dans la commune vous le voyez
d'ailleurs à l'écran en quelques-unes
des pièces du musée et bien tout
simplement première question quel est le
nom de ce musée
le musée de la batellerie non
c'est une bonne réponse une bonne
réponse pour Mathilde effectivement il
s'agit du musée de la batellerie à
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine créée en 1964
le but de ce musée à sa création c'était
de couronner l'activité plus
riculturelle d'une association la
Société des Amis de Conflans une
association présidée indirectement par
justement Louise Weiss et autre lien
avec Conflans-Sainte-Honorine en plus
d'être la présidente de cette
association elle avait aussi une maison
dans la commune prochaine question
Grégory tout de suite avec Elsa Triolet
son célèbre compagnon aussi Louis Aragon
il possédait une maison dans les
Yvelines vous souvenez de la commune
peut-être
saint-amand-en-yvelines alors
malheureusement c'est pas c'était pas la
question mais on va peut-être accorder
un bon point déjà alors on rappelle que
Elsa Triolet je vais y arriver est né en
Russie en 1900 en 1896 elle est
l'autrice de plus d'une trentaine
d'ouvrages et elle est surtout la
première femme lauréate d'une
distinction célèbre quelle est cette
distinction à votre avis
un célèbre prix de littérature
première femme de l'histoire à avoir
obtenu ce prix de littérature un prix de
littérature très connu le prix Goncourt
tout à fait très très bonne réponse en
face de moi qui a été décerné à Elsa
Triolet en 1945 pour l'année 1944 et son
ouvrage le premier accroc coûte 200
francs Elsa Triolet est aussi
journaliste et résistante elle repose
auprès de Louis Aragon dans le domaine
du Moulin de Villeneuve c'est l'autre
nom de ce de cette maison Elsa Triolet
Aragon à Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines on va
poursuivre regarder ce lieu tout de
suite qui va s'afficher sur l'écran son
nom est connu mais saurez-vous me dire
alors déjà est-ce que vous connaissez ce
domaine à Versailles
le domaine de Madame Elisabeth alors
saurez-vous me dire qui était Madame
Élisabeth j'attends un lien de parenté
avec un personnage très célèbre de
l'Histoire de France c'est pas la nièce
la nièce de Louis XVI quelque chose il
s'agit Louis XVI c'était pas sa nièce sa
sœur très bonne réponse en face voilà il
y a des bonnes réponses aujourd'hui
autour de la table et effectivement
Élisabeth de France c'est la dernière
fille du dauphin Louis-Ferdinand la le
fils de Louis XV et de Marie-Joseph de
Saxe et donc la sœur de Louis XVI
dernière sœur de Louis XVI de Louis XVII
aussi et de Charles X puisque ça a été
une fratrie qui a donné beaucoup de
droits à la France Louis XVI a fait donc
à sa majorité du domaine de Montreuil
qui va devenir ensuite le domaine de
Madame Elisabeth c'est le département
des Yvelines leur racheté en 1983
ème question 4e question mon prénom est
Tamara je suis né à Trappes en 1985 et
j'ai été formé par Olaf Siby fondateur
de la compagnie illicite dance avant
d'être repéré par le chanteur et
producteur Camaro au début des années
2000 mon premier succès s'intitule femme
de couleur qui suis-je
Shy'm très bonne réponse bravo enfin sur
la on a toutes les bonnes réponses ce
soir il s'agit effectivement de Shy'm
Tamara Martin de son vrai prénom qui a
sorti depuis le début de sa carrière 8
albums vendus plus d'un million
d'exemplaires tout de même et parmi les
distinctions peut citer avec quatre
énergies Music Awards dont trois pour
artistes francophones de l'année mon
Gabriel et Mathilde on va tenter de se
rattraper sur la dernière question il y
avait quand même une bonne réponse de la
part de Mathilde Gabriel vous étiez pas
loin aussi d'une bonne réponse mais qui
a été donné en face malheureusement
juste avant regardez ces images me
tourne à chaque fois vers notre écran de
retour qui est cette personne on parle
là d'une célèbre chanteuse danseuse et
meneuse de revues françaises voilà il y
a pas eu longtemps de suspense en
plateau effectivement Joséphine Baker
elle chanteuse danseuse meneuse de revue
comédienne l'artiste né en 1906 dans le
Missouri aux États-Unis elle débarque à
Paris en 1925 pour participer à la
funèbres au Théâtre des Champs-Élysées
elle entre dans la Résistance lors de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale et dans les
services de Contres espionnage elle va
militer ensuite pour
contredant Papou un contre les
discriminations raciales et le droit à
civique des personnes noires le lien
avec les Yvelines vous me direz et bien
c'est tout simplement qu'elle avait une
maison au Vésinet elle a vécu au Vésinet
entre 1929 et 1947 dans ça à Villa vous
avez peut-être vu d'ailleurs sa guépard
tchikita qui faisait partie de sa
messagerie elle avait des poules des
chèvres également mais aussi des moutons
mais aussi une léopard une guépard
pardon tchikita Joséphine Baker
disparaît en 1975 elle entre au Panthéon
en 2021 c'est la sixième femme dans
l'histoire à faire son entrée au
Panthéon et surtout la première femme
noire de l'histoire à être panthéonisée
merci beaucoup Grégory canari pour
toutes ces informations mais on remercie
surtout Mélanie Pauquet qui a été à
l'origine de la préparation de ce quiz
merci elle remercie également alors du
coup Catherine baron vous êtes la grande
gagnante de ce quiz avec trois trois
bonnes réponses je crois ou 4 4 bonnes
réponses pour pouvoir faire
vous aviez peut-être la première moi
j'ai un point je crois être suivantes
ont été une qui a été si si par Shy'm ça
a été donné par notre invité de la
poésie là-dedans
la maison Aragon ils font des choses
formidables et puis Joséphine Baker en
fait on a j'ai rendu un hommage en mot
une note bleue l'année dernière avec
l'équipe de Frida Kahlo donc c'était des
lectures et aussi de la musique où on a
parcouru un peu
les oeuvres les œuvres de Joséphine
Baker de cette femme extraordinaire
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le sel sera encore bien
nuageux sur l'ensemble du département
prévoyait quelques averses durant la
matinée au niveau des températures
comptées 9 degrés vers Mantes-la-Jolie
Houdan et Versailles et 8 degrés à
Rambouillet dans l'après-midi le ciel
sera toujours bien chargé avec de la
pluie côté température il fera 8 degrés
vers ou dans et contestait degrés dans
les secteurs de Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Rambouillet de fortes
rafales de vent sont également à prévoir
selon Météo France tout au long de la
journée et pour ce week-end quel temps
fera-t-il Gabriel et bien malgré les
températures fraîches le soleil est en
rendez-vous samedi dans la matinée
compter entre 3 et 4 degrés côté
température l'après-midi légère hausse
il fera 5 degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet
avant que la jolie et Versailles les
maximale reste fraîches avec 6 degrés
dimanche les températures sont en légère
hausse il fera 10 degrés à Versailles et
Rambouillet et 11 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan l'après-midi
le ciel reste ensoleillé et les
températures sont comprises entre deux
et 12 et 13 degrés
Gabriel donc plutôt intense sec pour ce
week-end exactement avec du soleil merci
beaucoup Gabriel c'est la fin de cette
émission merci pour votre fidélité je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]